signori facciamo questo gameplay vediamo
come sono chiamati da fuori oggi su main
crowe non solo su giva perché ovviamente
li faceva film ma questo è particolare è
un gioco serio anche perché oltre manica
di trattative e cioè si quindi poteva
vedere un pochettino che cosa che
abbiamo fuori allora innanzitutto vedo
che le ombre sono fatte bene sono meglio
delle mie si vede meglio mi hanno
spiegato che tra l'altro c'è la
possibilità di disattivare e riattivare
i drink racing così bellissima altro è
l'altro notare la pronuncia di
raytracing che proprio allora ragazzini
fare qualcosa di decente
innanzitutto voglio vedere un attimino
come questa stanza senza ray tracing qua
c'è un villaggio tutto a posto
molto carino e invece con il ray tracing
andiamo a cui estro per un attimo
pensavo che il tizio e villager si
sarebbe trasformato il mio padre però
ancora non ho inciso nel rinnovare
ragazzi alla prima vedere un pochettino
visto che queste questa una mappa te mi
sa che è stata fatta proprio apposta per
testare raytracing vediamo un attimo gli
effetti che mi sembrano veramente hot
la cosa che mi piace di più alla luce
soffusa però va bene io non è meglio non
lo sarei mai immaginato minecraft così
c'è anche perché non penso che devo
chiedere ma non credo che vi siano
installate delle delle mode grafiche
questo cambi state vanilla pure
raytracing fatti questo mi confermano
che queste senza molti grafica e l'altra
mappa che problemi invece ci aveva delle
nostre api allora questo per quanto
riguarda il villaggio ci siamo ci siamo
morale già visto prima
abbiamo anche ovviamente la caverna la
caverna immagino abbia un po degli
effetti oscuri lo vede in genere di un
momento che figo nuova bene che figata
ma che sta per accendere si spengono che
c'era l'inter c'è la domotica c'è la
domotica nella caverna bellissimo
criticate nostri tono senza commercio a
protetta non esiste questa cosa
la cloud stone che non esiste dentro
bellissima la crus nuovamente ti serve
proprio questa mappa 98 risultato no era
scivolata riesce ma kakà scassata aperti
ma dal mattino la fattura nella
piacevole grazie pari a diamanti che è
il corredo ci sono i diamanti ma dopo un
primo periodo logistica questa cosa
pietrangeli luce mora con eco minecraft
normale non esiste ma non c'è niente di
questa cosa è veramente pazzesca il
raggio di dio che mi ami computer
implode ecco le cose più belle comunque
sono ovviamente la lava e la globo per
quanto riguarda certo dentro le caverne
prendo natura forma non hai capito in
parte posso volare quindi in questo sto
seguendo il patto
no ragazzi veramente assurda questa cosa
ci sembra madonna ma è un'altra roba
una partita inizia era 20 incredibile
ragazzi aveva in sé col parte così
almeno non faccio il figo
allora andiamo avanti dovrebbe esserci
che nello che non riesco neanche ad
andare avanti nelle demo
questo è un castello di ghiaccio senza
gehrig cioè per niente e come vedi tu
con gli occhiali e sensoriali con i
chargers veramente che come non avevo
veramente mai provato minecraft sipe
tratto sembra che sembra che il computer
nostri sforzi in anche no spero che sono
solo veramente incredibile il riflesso
del di blocco di diamante normale non
c'è niente
si no fa ridere noto delle apa dovrei
fare del parto e mi hanno messo una
sfida se siete solo braccia però ho
imparato in tutti sti anni dentro tanto
se guardate la mia opera ragazzi c'è
solo il mio braccio
ora andiamo avanti vi faccio vedere
quanto sono stato bravo nel parco negli
ultimi anni
ora cosa mi ha insegnato pietro pensate
cosa può fare un ragazzo po indietro poi
pietro ci siamo
dovrebbe essere finita non sono qualcosa
che quando sembra che sembra shadow of
the colossus cioè diventata un'altra
roba
va bene allora abbiamo visto che i
riflessi e le luci funzionano penso che
questa sia la fine teoricamente del però
dalle nel villaggio che vi dò sempre non
l'ho visto per bene bellissimo non
ragazzi veramente incredibile allora
siamo tornati dov'eravamo all'inizio
direi che è a livello di ray tracing ci
siamo il mondo è veramente figo
adesso sono curioso di vedere come la
stessa cosa però con le mode grafiche
per adesso abbiamo capito che comunque
ci sta dentro bellissimo troviamo quelle
modi grafiche ragazzi allora ragazzi
siamo tornati sulla mappa quella con le
monde grafiche che mondografica ci sono
canali bra erba in seguito pure da parte
sotto c'è il marmo è diverso l'inizio di
superfici i livelli senti sembra
veramente casa mia questa è proprio
l'altra 2004 aveva i ragazzi adesso
vediamo un attimino con le mode grafica
domani va filippo che le luci sono
incredibili
vi presento a casa mia oggi facciamo
questa roba
praticamente questa è la porta del
garage di immagini ci sia una macchina
dentro non lo so ma non so se hanno
messo la moda macchina veramente figo
allora ci sono dei vasi di vetro di
dubbia provenienza che di dubbia utilità
soprattutto lui la madonna c'è il
sottoscala che lo stesso colore del
computer che sta usando in questo
momento
dopodiche c'e questa bellissima piscina
che dentro non e piscina se tu invece ti
la leva che questa qua compare una cosa
molto carina che hanno fatto vedere
prima che questa questa buona
pacchianata pro ci stava ovviamente
tolto rtx inesistente però va bene c'è
tra l'altro c'è una differenza abissale
beauvais
bellissima anche le imperfezioni delle
piastrelle
andiamo a sinistra c'è la discoteca
ovviamente in casa chi non è una
discarica cioè questo credo sia un bagno
senza i sanitari però vediamo di soavi
di che questi coach e garage ma nessuna
macchina allora proprio kasami andiamo
al piano di sotto troviamo il credo la
cantina non rose o mio dio si sta roba
questo qua ha dei gusti strani in quanto
per quanto riguarda l'arredamento pro
dove andiamo avanti
non riesco che anche uno specchio ma è
una donna perry è un riflesso quindi per
seconda davanti c'è io stavo andando
avanti pensavo che la stanza fosse lungo
andare i riflessi funzionano bene
perfetta andiamo a destra questo
riflesso ancora perfettamente vanessa
una parte riflessi inganno non
dovrebbero fare un labirinto degli
specchi in microsoft veri come in casa
in uscirne solo per le reti ovviamente
c'è una famiglia ed era quella senza
cioè non esiste è una cosa completamente
diversa aver ucciso lamentato come si
vede si vede perché il corridoio senza
non si vede niente quindi proprio le
luci si attivano veramente cicas a cosa
andiamo adesso sì e credo che ci faccia
da ieri ti veramente sinistri quello che
abita in staccata qua perché non ne vedo
senza il terrore però un'altra discoteca
in casa nel caso non ci fosse abbastanza
spazio per la gente che ha invitato al
piano di sopra di così va delle porte ti
fanno entrare nel matrix mentre ragazzi
al piano di sopra abbiamo
visto che ancora non ci sono andato
manca l'ultima stanza vuole ultima
istanza d'aver da controllare bellissima
bellissima la vetrata
peccato che sia notte fuori e in tutta
questa casa comunque ragazzi manca una
cosa non ti sia piaciuta questa era dove
essere rtx di minecraft molto molto
carina ringrazio emilia per avermi fatto
provare questa questa mappa e avermi
fatto provare a punto la la la casa
quando uscirà ovviamente ci parlo dei
video perché merita un sacco speriamo
non mi imploda il computer
ricordate i ragazzi vi lascio il link in
descrizione per chi informazioni sulle
reti che sicuramente quindi controllate
alla descrizione di lasciato mi faccia
dire iscrivetevi al canale e noi ci
vediamo come sempre anno prossimo video
bellaria
[Musica]